>> Laura: IT'S FRIDAY.
THAT MEANS IT'S TIME FOR FRIDAY
FOLLIES.
STRANGE COVERAGE OF "STRANGER
THINGS."
A BACKLASH OVER A NEW LITTLE
MERMAID.
AND THE RISE AGAIN OF THE MURSE.
JOINING US RAYMOND.
NETFLIX, "TRAININGER
NETFLIX, "STAININGER
NETFLIX, "STRANINGER
NETFLIX, "STRANGNGER
NETFLIX, "STRANGERER
NETFLIX, "STRANGER THINGS" TENS
OF MILLIONS WATCH THIS.
NOW THERE IS A CONTROVERSY OVER
THE SEXUALITY OF A YOUNG BOY.
>> YES.
SEASON THREE.
>> Laura: WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> BILL BUYER THE CENTRAL
CHARACTER IN THE STORY AND A
YOUNG CHARACTER ON THE SHOW.
DEA SCENE THIS SEASON AND SOME
OF THE MEDIA THOUGHT IT RAISED
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE CHARACTER'S
SEXUALITY.
BARE IN MIND THE CHARACTER IS 12
YEARS OLD.
HE HAS PLAYED GAMES WITH HIS
FRIENDS.
NOW HE ONLY WANTS TO TALK ABOUT
GIRLS.
WATCH.
>> YOU'RE DESTROYING EVERYTHING,
AND FOR WHAT.
A STUPID GIRL.
>> ELLE IS NOT STUPID.
IT'S NOT MY FAULT YOU DON'T LIKE
GIRLS.
>> WHAT DID YOU THINK, REALLY.
THAT WE WOULDN'T GET
GIRLFRIENDS.
THAT WE WOULD SIT IN THE
BASEMENT AND PLAY GAMES FOR THE
REST OF OUR LIVES.
>> YA, I GUESS I DID.
>> OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A INNOCENT
SCENE ABOUT A CHILD GOING
THROUGH GROWING PAINS.
PEOPLE IN SOCIAL MEDIA SAID WILL
BUYERS IS GAY.
THEN A REPORTER CON FRONTED THE
14-YEAR-OLD BOY PLAYING WILL AND
ASKED HIM THE QUESTION.
THE ACTOR SAID I JUSTIN THEY
WERE RETT IT AS HE'S NOT READY
TO GROW UP HE WANTS TO GROW UP
AND PLAY IN THE BASEMENT LIKE
OLD TIMES.
WHY MUST WE SEXUALIZE KIDS,
LAURA. ONE OF THE BEST KNOWN
KIDS IN THE WORLD BECAUSE OF
THIS TELEVISION SHOW AND THE
SUCCESS OF IT.
>> Laura: EVERYONE SHOULD KNOW,
IF YOU HAVEN'T SEEN THE SHOW, IT
TAKES US COME BACK TO THE 80s.
>> 80s.
>> Laura: EVERYTHING SEEMS A LOT
SIMPLER IN MANY WAYS IN THE
80s THERE.
IS A HUNGER FOR SIMPLER TIMES
AND SIMPLER THINGS.
THERE WAS A LITTLE, MAYBE A
LITTLE MORE INNOCENCE.
>> THIS IS THE ADOLESCENCE OF
AMERICA, LAURA. ADULTS STILL
ADOLESCENCE PROJECTING THEIR
ANXIETY AND SEXUALITY ONTO THE
YOUNG CHARACTERS.
THEY'RE KIDS.
IT'S A KID CHARACTER.
I LOVE THAT KNOW A SNAP SAID,
WILL BEING GAY ISN'T THE POINT
...
>> HE HAS MORE WISDOM THEN THE
ADULTS ASKING THESE QUESTIONS.
>> Laura: THAT'S A PROFOUND
COMMENT.
SOME KIDS ARE QUIETER, MORE
SENSITIVE, ARTISTIC.
ADULTS COME IN AND SAY YOU MUST
BE THIS.
LET THEM GROW UP AND MAKE THEIR
OWN DECISIONS THAFPLTZ WHAT I
DON'T LIKE.
EVERYONE IS TRYING TO SEXUALIZE
CHILDREN.
FOR THEIR OWN AGENDA.
I DON'T LIKE THAT AT ALL.
>> LAURA, IT WAS REPORTED THERE
WAS A HUGE BACKLASH AGAINST
DISNEY'S ANNOUNCEMENT THEY WERE
CASTING A BLACK ACTRESS AND
SINGER, HALL E-BAYLY, FOR
"LITTLE MERMAID."
IT WAS REPORTED ON THE
#NOTMYAERIALMOVEMENT.
THE NAME OF THE MERMAID.
IT WAS SUPPOSEDLY DRIVEN BY
RACISTS THAT A BLACK ACTRESS WAS
PLAYING A WHITE CARTOON
CHARACTER.
THIS WAS ALL CREATED BY THOSE
DEFENDING THE MULTI RACIAL
CASTING.
A WASHINGTON POST PIECE TIED THE
RACIAL UP RISING TO DONALD
TRUMP.
CAN YOU BELIEVE IT I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE CONTROVERSY IS.
IT'S A CARTOON CHARACTER.
AIKAU CATION MERMAID UNDER THE
SEA.
IT'S FICTION.
WHO CARES IF SHE'S WHITE, GREEN,
BLUE, YELL OH,.
>> Laura: WHAT IS THE HISTORY OF
THE STORY.
>> A NORWEGIAN STORY.
THERE WAS A BLACK VERSION OF
"HELLO, DOLLY" THERE WASN'T AN
UPRISING.
MY PROBLEM IS THE WHIPPING UP
RACIAL HATRED TO DRAW ATTENTION
TO THE PROJECT.
DISNEY IS DOING THESE LIVE
ACTION RECREATIONS.
THEY'RE NOT -- THEY'RE DOING
LION FRAME THIS WEEK.
A FRAME FOR FRAME RECREATION OF
THE OLD CARTOON.
THIS SCENE IS SO POWERFUL.
WATCH.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO CHILDREN
AGAIN I'M THE LIONESS AND
PROTECT THE CUBS.
>> YOU CALL THAT THE CIRCLE OF
STRIFE.
>> Laura: CIRCLE OF STRIFE.
>> NANCY WILL BE SOME MUFASSA.
APPARENTLY "FRIENDS" HAD IT
RIGHT.
THEY SAID MEN REALLY DO LOVE
THEIR BAGS.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, MAKE FUN ALL
YOU WANT THIS.
IS A GREAT BAG.
IT'S AS HANDY AS IT IS BECOMING.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND
SOMETHING DOESN'T MAKE IT WRONG.
FROM NOW ON YOU HAVE TO GET USE
TO THE FACT THAT JOEY COMES WITH
THE BAG.
>> Laura: JOEY MAY COME WITH A
BAG, HE DITCH IT DID LATER.
I DOUBT MANY GUYS  ARE CARRYING
THESE THINGS.
THIS IS PREMIERING, MURSES,
PURSES FOR MEN ON THE RUN WAY.PU
PURSES FOR MEN ON THE RUN WAY.PH
PURSES FOR MEN ON THE RUN WAY.PI
PURSES FOR MEN ON THE RUN WAY.PR
PURSES FOR MEN ON THE RUN WAY.P,
PURSES FOR MEN ON THE RUN WAY.PL
PURSES FOR MEN ON THE RUN WAY.PU
PURSES FOR MEN ON THE RUN WAY.PE
PURSES FOR MEN ON THE RUN WAY.PA
PURSES FOR MEN ON THE RUN WAY.PD
PURSES FOR MEN ON THE RUN WAY.PM
PURSES FOR MEN ON THE RUN WAY.PR
PURSES FOR MEN ON THE RUN WAY.PE
PURSES FOR MEN ON THE RUN WAY.PA
SELLING CROSS BODY BAGS AND
CLUTCHES FOR GUYS.
>> LACROSSE PLAYERS AND EVEN
NICK JONAHS HAS BEEN SPOTTED
WITH THIS THING.
THAT'S A LEATHER CLUTCH.
A LEATHER CLUTCH.
I GUESS BACKPACKS ARE OUT AND
MURSES ARE IN.
>> I'M NOT EVEN FROM BACKPACKS.
IF YOU HAVE GRADUATED FROM
COLONEL SKPEBLG YOU'RE A GUY,
UNLESS YOU'RE HIKING OR IN A
SPORT.
IF YOU DO SPORTS FOR A LIVING,
BUT IF YOU'RE GOING TO A JOB
EVERY DAY SOME HOW THE BACKPACK.
>> THE OLD BRIEFCASE.
>> Laura: I THINK THE BRIEFCASE.
BRING BACK THE BRIEFCASE.
>> GO BACK --
>> Laura: YES.
>> I DON'T MIND SATCHELS IF
YOU'RE A NEWS BOY.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND ARE YOU
BACK IN THE 1800s.
A SATCHEL.
THANKS IS APPROPRIATE FOR A MAN
TO CARRY.
>> Laura: IN THE 1800s.
>> THESE DAINTY CROSS BAGS AND
CLUTCHES.
WHAT IS NEXT SHOES TO MATCH THE
DARN THINGS.
>> Laura: IT'S ALL, IT'S ALL THE
GENDER BENDING.
THEY'RE ALL CAPITALIZING.
>> IT'S A BAD LOOK IT MAKES YOU
LOOK TO COIN A PHRASE THAT
DONALD TRUMP USES ALL THE TIME,
VERY WEAK.
NO BAG HERE.
>> Laura: STAY SAFE IN NEW